come on we all love getting packages
[Applause]
[Music]
KaBlam a day late but worth the wait so
yes I have got my technical issues
sorted out and I got to see the latest
episode of series 11 of Doctor Who and
I'm not even gonna beat around the bush
it's great I like I I'm going back and
forth a little bit as to whether or not
I like it more than demons of the Punjab
but I think I do
I'd really love the emotional resonance
of demons of the Punjab but like this is
just this is just great Doctor Who it's
I love basically everything about this
I love the premise I love the pacing I
love the reveals I love the characters I
love all of this I love the fact that
it's it's it's taking on a target a
relevant target it's very much a
commentary on Amazon yet it's not
necessarily definitively painting anyone
other than someone who doesn't value
human life as the bad guy and that's
really great the robots the the curb
lamb ma'am ma'am
man um because it is just the right
balance of yeah I can see why you know a
corporate design would think that looks
friendly but it looks creepy and like
not necessarily as a straight one-to-one
but it does remind me of kind of the
effect of like the slightly cartoonish
mannequins that like Old Navy use for a
little while those kind of creeped me
out too and I feel this does a lot
better than some other attempts that new
who has done at creepy robots I think
this is more effective than the smilers
from the Beast below I think it's more
effective than the hand robots from the
girl who waited I think it's more
effective than the emoji robots from
smile most of those I have I was
perfectly fine with but I feel like this
nails the whole angle of being feeling
like something that human beings would
actually design while at the same time
managing to be creepy so I liked them a
lot
I think I think this probably is my
favorite episode I think
puts it over the top is this is my
favorite work from Jodie Whittaker so
far because for the first time she not
only does she take command of the
situation but it feels much more
balanced in terms of the doctor to
companion involvement ratio it feels
like she is a much more an active part
of this story then it has felt like for
most of the other episodes of this
series so far she comes in she she Abbey
she wants to get a sense of things she
wants to you know help she wants to
figure out what's going on she wants to
help and she takes control in the right
moments she you know knows when to back
off but like I get it when I when I said
before I kind of wanted the doctor to
take control I didn't mean literally
take control of the of the situation
like demand that everyone listened to
her but I did want her to take command
of the attention of my attention as an
audience member and she does that here
so this this is for her as absolute
highlight the other companions get some
good stuff I think again yes kinda gets
the short shrift not that she is not
good in it it's just better stuff is
given for Ryan and Graham I'm really
getting partial to hearing Graham you
know called the doctor doc I'm quite
likey Matt and they're like I'm probably
just gonna ramble through a whole bunch
of little things that I just liked I
love I liked the Fez and I liked that
there was an engagement like Oh must
over ordered this a while back so it's
not that you know narrative Lee it's not
that this doctors trying to be the old
doctors that oh yeah Matt Smith totally
would have ordered one of these things
then Oh timing wise this is just how it
worked out and that was cool and funny
and actually looks surprisingly good on
her I don't know I don't want her to
keep wearing it but it was kind of nice
it was fun and there I like the sense of
scale to this location there are some
really well-constructed shots of the
warehouse of the conveyors of the army
of delivery bots it's it's all really
well done in in terms of giving you a
sense of the size of this operation and
all the guest performances are really
good including the ones
like seem a bit more questionable so
like the the human I've got me chief HR
is what she is what she is I for some
reason I'm forget about the collar and
then the the like the on-site manager
and I like in both of their cases like
their there's something off about them
like she is not paying as much attention
to the people who theoretically she's
looking out for whereas he you know he's
playing the tough boss but like there's
something else going on there and I got
that sense early on well the doctor kind
of confronted him and then he backed
down I was like that's intriguing cuz
the cliched the expectation would be you
know he just blasters and but he didn't
he was like yeah and goes away I'm like
I feel like there's more to this guy and
that's the whole thing I feel like
that's this whole episode of nutshell I
feel like there's more here not like
it's a massively deeper intricate or
overly involved story but this is one of
those cases where a concept was hit upon
and then the final result was just
polished to a mirror shine every
decision that was made about what to do
and where to go and how to tackle these
things how to handle these characters
how they react how the plot plans out
they looked at their options and went
with one of the more intelligent choices
they never went with the cliched choice
even like the about like there were two
things that I called but I still didn't
feel like I was ahead of the show
I called that it was this well I thought
it was gonna be the robots but I more or
less called that it was the system
calling for help not a human being but I
still you know went with that revelation
and worked for me I also called the Kara
was gonna die but I was completely wrong
about the circumstances because my
assumption was that she was going to die
because well here's a new person who
gets introduced who we like they always
die so that we know the threat and maybe
we get a little sad if they do it right
but it she didn't die to up the stakes
she died for more of a plot relevant
reason she was she was put in a
situation where she died forced in that
situation by the system trying to send a
message to Charlie and that whole thing
was great I love this whole thing where
they try and confront
he's like you know the system has to
stop the system is fought and they're
like the system is doing everything
possible to stop what you're doing
because what you're doing is wrong and
he's like well no I and but he he won't
accept he came in to this whole
situation so certain of himself he was
not prepared to accept new information
and taken the fact that the system is
trying to save people from him and it's
responding to his actions but he won't
accept that because he already made up
his mind and I like what the doctor says
is that you know the systems are not
inherently evil they it's the way that
they are wheeled in which it's not a
sentiment that I'm sure I actually agree
with not all the time at any rate but I
liked the nuanced approach to this I
like that the it wasn't totally led that
the system and the company was that
ker-blam wasn't totally let off the hook
for the damage that its practices and
how few humans have jobs causes like
there's a recognition that okay charlie
is and charlie is an extreme example and
the worst possible iteration of this
problem but he does still represent a
problem that exists and a problem that
should be addressing his being ignored
and so I like that all of that is
layered in like nobody is perfect in
this story yet at the same time that
doesn't detract from it having a fairly
rollicking fun pace and movement as it
gets along this is just masterfully
balanced from top to bottom I I don't
have a complaint like any I've always
had I like a professional buzzkill
I've been called that more than a few
times I should add that to my business
card actually but you know I always find
something to complain about and
especially this this series of Doctor
Who I have usually found things to
complain about but no I'd loved this
this was great
and I'm also nervous because this is two
really good episodes in a row and they
are two episodes that Chris Chibnall did
not write I'll sort of see if my
suspicions are confirmed as we get to
the tail end and you know the next
couple episodes and then get back into
ones that he actually wrote because I
have a sneaking suspicion that when I do
my end of series wrap up on this I'm
going to be most critical of him
specifically but I'm gonna let those
ideas continue to percolate and wait for
the last bits of evidence ie the last
few shows to come out but ker-blam I
loved it
did you am i over selling it what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it whole bunch
of stuff you can do because there's
buttons and there's links including one
to my patreon if you like supporting me
that way
oh plus you know what since I never
pitched this hard but you know what
there's a p.o box down there too if you
want to send me packages and have me get
all excited at opening stuff you know
just a thought but there's other things
for you to look down in the description
as well but if you don't want to look at
any of it you know what that's fine too
because at the end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]